rock paper robot is a design firm that
specializes in invention and fabrication
of kinetic furniture that levitating
tables robotic chandeliers I truly love
physics concepts and I wanted to inspire
wonder make new you know connections in
the brain
rock paper robot is currently animating
the transition period I think we started
with personalized handmade products
because that's what I was capable of and
I would hire the cheapest person to do
the job which was limited myself and
then I would do it and this is not a
good business model I do have to pick
between the artists hat and the
entrepreneur hat I could sell a high-end
piece for ten times more than I do if I
was considered an artist but we could
only handle putting out one piece at a
time we have 50 other projects in the
buffer in order to be able to actually
get to all these other pieces that I
want to be able to do I need to have
some sustainable way to produce that
volume one of the big challenges for me
is to be able to start to delegate what
I need to have done to run the business
so that I can beer back into a more
creative role if that means that I'm not
CEO this is fine I didn't want to just
have a company I wanted to make
beautiful things our latest product we
decided to mass-produce it it slides
down from the wall and comes out to any
length we started already to manufacture
overseas we have 500 pre-orders for the
table so now we are about to increase
our output by probably a thousand times
and that is a tremendous amount of
growth